(upbeat music)
- Today I'm cutting my best friend's hair.
- I'm outgoing in a more spiritual way,
and she's really outgoing,
like I feel like she's
the next broadway star.
- She would look ravishing
in a long, longer bob,
kind of similar to Kate
Bosworth, I'm thinking.
- That's a lot of hair.
- So, I think the best haircut style
would be like the long
layers, like Sofia Vergara.
- It makes me really nervous that
I can't see you cutting my hair.
Like, there's no mirror.
- I'm a little nervous,
but at the same time,
I have a lot of trust in her,
so I think this will be good.
(ominous music)
- Sorry if I'm touching your boobie.
(scissors cutting)
(squealing)
(nervous laughter)
- No, it looks really good.
- Maybe 'cause I have thick, wavy hair,
it won't show too much.
- Yeah.
- If it's bad.
(laughing)
- No, it's not bad.
- It just sounds like a ton of hair
coming off of my head right now.
- You have particularly loud hair.
- Are you cutting upwards?
- No.
(laughing)
- I don't think that does anything.
- Don't look at it.
- It's not nearly as bad as
you think it is, I promise.
- Well, I didn't think it was that bad.
(ticking music)
- Well, if you ever doubt
that I trust you, Elizabeth,
we have this video to look back on.
- I'm just going to do like
a trim this right here,
because, I'm just gonna
keep this nice and even.
- You keep saying "even,"
like it's not currently.
- No, it is even for the most part.
- Turn to me real quick.
- I love how you're trying to even it out
by bringing one hair over to the other.
I know what you're doing!
(laughing)
- This looks not bad.
- What are we thinking?
- I don't think it looks bad at all,
I think it's a good amount of hair.
- It not looking bad does
not mean that it looks good.
(increasingly intense music)
- Go ahead.
- Okay.
- Right, I know what I'm doing.
- Kind of.
- This is chopped, chopped, a lot off.
- Chop, chop.
(laughing)
- Okay, okay.
I love you.
(yelling)
- She should not cut anybody else's hair.
(laughing)
Ever again.
- That's probably true.
- I am surprised, but I am happy with it,
I'm really happy with it.
She didn't cut it too short,
and there is some layering.
Very minor, but there is
some layering going on here,
I see it, it's good.
(sighing)
- I still love you.
- Aww, she loves me.
- But, I'm definitely going
to the salon tomorrow.
(laughing)
- I thought I was going to
be stressing out over there,
but I had a good time.
- Yeah.
- And you look great, I love it.
- I love it too, thank you.
(upbeat music)